l'eau une denrée de plus en plus rare en
France une trentaine de départements
sont d'ores et déjà classés au minimum
en vigé au minimum en vigilance
sécheresse vous les voyez ici en gris
cela va de l'alerte au premier
restrictions comme dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales le déficit hydrique
en Loir-et-Cher et en Indre-et-Loire
nous préserve pour le moment des
restrictions mais il inquiète et nous
vont un premier niveau de classement
depuis mars informé des bonnes pratiques
préserver tant que faire se peut la
ressource par exemple dans les jardins
familiaux où les jardiniers peuvent
arroser à des horaires précis la ville
de Tours a même mis en place des
disjoncteurs d'eau romain Delville
fraises betterave fève petits pois
artichaut Jean-Claude cultive c'est 200
mètres carrés de jardin familiaux à
Saint-François avec grand soin tellement
je paye enfin c'est du pays de bois
exactement pour garder une certaine
humidité au pied des fraisiers voilà
afin de d'arroser un minimum arroser un
minimum tel est le grand sujet du moment
alors que l'Indre-et-Loire est placé
depuis le 16 mars en vigilance
sécheresse depuis quelques années on a
des restrictions et avec des arrêtés
préfectoraux qui nous sommes de
d'arroser à des orbies imprécises là
pour l'instant on est toujours en
vigilance séchées c'est-à-dire qu'on
fait attention qu'on recommande nos
jardiniers de pailler leur planche pour
éviter d'avoir trop de consommation et
puis on le répète et on leur dit de pas
arroser dans certains jardins familiaux
comme ici ceux de la bergerie la mairie
va même plus loin elle a fait installer
des disjoncteurs d'eau sur les 1300
jardins familiaux propriét de la ville
55% sont équipés ça permet tout
simplement à obliger les adhérents des
associations à arroser au bon moment de
la journée donc on a une plage horaire
qui est du matin donc de 6h à 10h et il
y a une deuxième planche horaire qui est
de 18h à 23h au départ elle était plutôt
18 22 on s'est rendu compte que les
beaux jours finalement l'été c'est
plutôt 23 donc on a poussé à 23 et ça
permet aussi d'alléger un peu le poids
pour les présidents et présidente
Desjardins qui sont sinon obligés de
faire la police de l'eau et c'est pas
toujours facile pour eux d'autant
qu'après la vigilance sécheresse
intervienne généralement les
restrictions d'eau en 2022 les premières
avaient été prises début juillet les
jardiniers craignent quelles
interviennent plutôt cette année